[Musique]
le code d'attaqué
du coup les ifi malawi bruit chauffe
tueur après tu auras pas plus mal avec
le plâtre un bras cassé
une randonneuse blessés dans le cirque
de mafate une vilaine chute une femme
ivre
ce jour là comme tous les jours les
urgences du chu de saint denis vont
accueillir toutes les souffrances de
ville
ce jour là alors que flotte sur
l'hôpital le drapeau de la grève
l'infirmier arnaud mots à lui prend son
service à 6 heures comme tous ses
collègues des urgences il est lui-même
grévistes rêve toujours il n'est pas
encore six heures trente et un jeune
homme arrive avec des policiers
très appliqués dans un accident en état
d'ivresse
le jeune homme est menotté car il s'est
rebellé au moment de son interpellation
jégo quelques minutes plus tard arrive
un homme très agité
l'homme est emmené vers le service des
soins est placé dans un box en attendant
qu'un médecin vienne l'examiner
et ça n'arrête pas les pompiers amène
maintenant un homme en détresse
respiratoire
dès l'arrivée d'un patient l'infirmier
d'accueil prend la température
l'attention et contrôler la glycémie
une première évaluation qui permet de
déterminer le degré d'urgence maintenant
à chaque patient une couleur est
attribuée du rouge pour les extrême
urgence aux bleus qui devra parfois
attendre plusieurs heures
cette femme par exemple a été classée
orange
elle souffre de calcul haut rhin la
douleur est terrible mais elle va devoir
attendre plus de deux heures avant de
voir un médecin
allez on y va après on va vous mettre
une perfusion je pense que c'est le
meilleur pour soulager mais ça va aller
[Musique]
cet homme lui a été ramassé en état
d'ivresse profond sur le bord du chemin
après après il est bleu bleu cela veut
dire qu'il va attendre plusieurs heures
se fera de toute façon il dort
profondément bon généralement voilà on
les laisse la plupart 24 heures chez
nous et puis après ils repartent quand
qui sont mieux quoi
allik sommes attaqués elle s'est fait
mordre par le coq qu'elle tentait
d'attraper du coup l'effet malawi bruits
chauffe ça ne l'a pas empêché de
préparer le civet mais elle aussi va
devoir attendre maintenant pour le
moment à part signer une urgence y
arrive un photon au minimum une heure et
demie mais tout le monde n'est pas aussi
compréhensif
arrivé à l'accueil avec son fils blessé
cet homme ne comprend pas qu'il faille
attendre aussi longtemps dans l'helmand
la paupière sunny paris
on jase là point de rupture
[Musique]
madame c'est encore moins à l'infirmité
tout à l'heure il faut nous faire une
petite prise de sang inquiète paris fera
pas mal
plus fatigués
[Musique]
ouais ya des patients qui oui
malheureusement leur état permet pas
trop de communautés communiqué va après
samuel adopter une posture qui peut les
rassurer il ya la communication non
verbale aussi qui peut intervenir donc
par le toucher et tout est là ils
peuvent ressentir qu'ils peuvent être en
confiance et voilà qu'on prend vraiment
soin d'eux c'est maintenant un homme
victime d'un infarctus qui arrive
son rythme cardiaque est tombé très bas
à 25 pulsations par minute
immédiatement il est emmené au déchocage
une salle où l'on prend en charge les
urgences vitales rapidement
l'échographie permet de diagnostiquer
une artère bouchée
il faut opérer d'urgence on appelle la
famille et on essaye de retirer
l'alliance n'ont pas bien ça avant cela
ils descendent tous allés là un dernier
baiser et direction le bloc opératoire
nate jalleli station pas super impatient
arnaud se dirige vers le toit de
l'hôpital où un hélicoptère vient de se
poser
arrivé sur le toit d'un soleil
l'hélicoptère est déjà reparti laissant
là deux randonneurs blessés à la suite
de chutes dans le cirque de mafate
madame ça fait mal
[Musique]
c'est pareil bon courage en fin
d'après-midi la police est de retour et
même deux équipes de police arrivés en
même temps avec un jeune homme
interpellé en état d'ivresse et un vieil
homme ivre également un habitué des
urgences qui vient de callas et un
camion de pompiers
la médecin ausculte l'un et l'autre puis
délivre les certificats qui autorise des
policiers a emmené les deux hommes en
cellule de dégrisement ou en garde à vue
oui on va faire la perfusion qu'on a dit
monsieur pour ce travail
arnaud touche 2200 euros par mois
savoir que c'est un médecin qui fait
qu'on revient qu'on travaille la nuit
qu'on trahit le week-end qu'on travaille
les jours fériés beaucoup
ouais malheureusement bien ternes heures
en trois ans j'ai vu beaucoup de
collègues partir donc je pense que la
durée de vie d'un infirmier aux urgences
aux alentours de 5 ans indien
[Musique]
cette femme ou ci est une habituée des
urgences
oui mais la poule d euros bello les
pantins sortie à la regard ne tient pas
debout tu commences à fait là dehors ça
tombait alors gardons des fermes déjà
proposé en vain typique no alors qu'il
entame sa douzième heure de travail
arnaud l'emmène vers une salle d'examen
on est confronté sur une journée à
diverses situations ça va de l'urgence
vraiment vital qui a pris à la gestion
des personnes effectivement qui sont
dans des états d'ivresse par exemple où
il faut savoir trouver les mots pour
éviter d'arriver à des situations
d'agressivité voilà ça c'est notre
quotidien d'urgence on traite pas que
l'urgence vitale n'en traite surtout
voilà l'urgence sociale la misère
sociale
l'urgent psychologique ça ça fait voilà
90 95 % de prise en charge
c'était une journée calme aux urgences
80 admission aujourd'hui certains jours
on en compte jusqu'à 120